what that's a vivid memory that you
cannot this is real it is here is a
white mammal dreads
is he in jail no he got um three years
probation
three years probation isn't that
something isn't that something and that
that will stay with you for life you
laugh at it you joke about it it
probably still is disturbing well I've
had to do a lot I didn't realize that
was staying with me I would kind of like
because I've always been able to kind of
like joke about things and disassociate
but I was really dragging this man with
me I had I had a realization maybe a
couple years ago where I just I was
doing a meditation
and um in the meditation they have you
like standing on a rock and I would
always go to this rock behind my high
school
like why am I always on this one [ __ ]
Woods like right outside where all this
traumatic and I would anytime there was
like Woods involved I was always
visioning myself there and then they
were like have someone that hurt you
come to you and apologize so my teacher
came to me and apologized I'm like this
was my stuff I'm taking it back it's not
for you and I kind of realized in that
that I had been just dragging this guy
I've been thinking about it talking
about it every day how many years after
20 20 years oh so he got in trouble back
then though he got in trouble when I was
yeah right but you were still dragging
it I was thinking about all the time I
was like I was so like
yeah it was just really like
tight and scared I have like Jaw
problems and stuff I work on that jaw
problems jaw problems I have sweaty
armpits hyper Hydraulics you grind your
teeth and these are all things that was
there all of a sudden just just This
Moment of clarity that this is the cause
of all this how do I get rid of it how
do you get rid of it it's not just that
though because the jaw stuff happened
after my car accident I think that was I
don't know I don't think it was as much
structurally like in my skeleton that
the problem started happening I think it
was more like oh [ __ ] I can't like trust
that I'm gonna get the places I need to
get safely I think it was just sort of
like you didn't trust anyone yeah what
was